[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann
das sind die wichtigsten themen von
heute
impfpflicht ja oder nein im bundestag
diskutieren die abgeordneten erstmals
die verschiedenen vorschläge
antwort an moskau in diesen minuten
reagieren nato und usa auf die
russischen forderungen weitere gespräche
sollen folgen
und deutscher sieg beim nachtslalom
limesstraße gewinnt das weltcup rennen
in schladming und fährt nun mit gold
hoffnungen nach peking
alle parteien im bundestag außer der afg
plädieren dafür dass sich möglichst
viele menschen gegen korona impfen
lassen umstritten ist allerdings ob eine
impfpflicht eingeführt werden soll heute
debattierten erstmals der bundestag
darüber die abgeordneten im bundestag
die regierung will keinen eigenen
gesetzentwurf vorlegen die abgeordneten
entwickeln fraktionsübergreifend
gruppenanträge bislang gibt es drei
modelle den antrag gegen die impfpflicht
begründung der staat könne keine
impfpflicht umsätzen zweite idee eine
impfpflicht ab 18 zeitlich und auf drei
dosen begrenzt ungeimpften droht bußgeld
schließlich der dritte vorschlag
impfpflicht ab 50 nach einem arzt
gespräch und wenn sich die erforderliche
impfquote nicht einstellt über eine
besondere debatte heute daniel putzen
keiner der drei anträge stammt aus der
feder des gesundheitsministers der
gerade eben mehr als drei stunden nach
debatten beginn ans rednerpult trat aus
neutralitätsgründen wolle keinen eigenen
antrag vorliegen dennoch plädiert er für
die impfpflicht
wir werden nicht zurückkommen zu dem
leben was wir geliebt und geschätzt
haben ohne dass wir jetzt den spaten
drehen ohne dass wir uns gemeinsam
entstand und die dreifache info ist der
sichere weg diese freiheit zurück zu
erlangen der antrag der eine impfpflicht
ab 50 vorsieht wie sie etwa in italien
bereits gibt wurde ebenfalls von
abgeordneten der ampel beworben gegen
eine allgemeine impfpflicht ist seit
langem die afd wir sind an einem punkt
angelangt an dem impfstoffe schon fast
eine religiöse stellung erhalten wer
nicht glaubt und von seinem grundrecht
auf selbstbestimmung gebrauch macht ist
automatisch ausgeschlossen für den schon
vorliegenden antrag gegen eine
impfpflicht bei einer seiner urheber wir
müssen respektieren dass es durchaus
bedenkenswerte psychologische oder
religiöse gründe gibt eine impfung für
sich persönlich abzulehnen insbesondere
dass wir mittlerweile wissen dass der
fremdschutz durch eine impfung kaum mehr
gegeben ist widerspruch hierzu etwa von
den grünen ich bin überzeugt wir können
diese impfung verfassungsgemäß
ausgestalten und ich lade sie nochmals
alle sehr herzlich ein an diesen
gemeinsamen initiativen in den
verschiedenen gruppen mitzuarbeiten
die union warf der neuen regierung
unterdessen mit blick auf eben diese
unterschiedlichen anträge mangelnde
führung vor
können was wir erleben das ist
arbeitsverweigerung der bundesregierung
und eine missachtung der opposition
thema auch praktische fragen etwa was im
falle einer impfpflicht bei verstößen
drohte
nicht ohne sanktion ist keine pflicht
also ging es doch letztlich
wahrscheinlich nur als sanktion um
geldbußen aber wer nicht zahlt oder
nicht zahlen kann kriegt stattdessen das
verträgt unsere gesellschaft nicht
wieviel orientierung diese debatte nun
bot werden die nächsten parlaments-
wochen zeigen der weitere plan erste
lesung im februar abstimmung mitte märz
die bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
hatte sich eine faire und konstruktive
debatte gewünscht theo koll in berlin
wurde das erfüllt
also meines erachtens ja das waren
durchaus respektvoll stunden heute im
bundestag und die ernsthaftigkeit des
themas die zeigte sich ja auch im umgang
miteinander hilfreich war sicher auch
dass zwischen fragen nicht zugelassen
waren die dienen ja ansonsten gerne mal
als eine art rhetorischer nadel sticht
das ganze hieß ja heute orientierungs
debatte aber ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
halte es eher für unwahrscheinlich dass
ich noch viele abgeordnete vom austausch
der argumente umstand stimmen lassen
denn wer die korona zeit nicht in
kompletter informations isolation
verbracht hat der kennt natürlich alle
für und wider argumente die debatte
scheint er teil eines politischen
prozesses zu sein quasi der lange
übergang vom allgemeinen versprechen
dass es keine impfpflicht geben wird hin
zur politischen vermittlung der
notwendigkeit und dazu ist das parlament
natürlich auch der richtige ort
dankeschön für diese einschätzung theo
koll
von der allgemeinen impfpflicht bis zur
ablehnung war heute alles dabei in der
orientierungs debatte die wichtigsten
argumente für und gegen eine impfpflicht
können sie nachlesen bei zdf heute oder
in der heute
rund
444.000 menschen haben sich gestern in
deutschland gegen korona impfen lassen
die infektionszahlen gehen weiter nach
oben das robert koch institut
registrierte
164.000 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages ein neuer höchstwert und 51
1677 mehr als vor einer woche
166 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
dazu die sieben tage incidents steigt
auf 9
140,6
[Applaus]
pcr tests sind bekanntlich knapp und das
hat folgen etwa in nordrhein westfalen
dort hat die regierung kurzfristig die
test regeln für die grundschulen
geändert bisher gab es pcr tests bei
einem positiven ergebnis wurden die
proben noch einmal einzeln untersucht
wieder per pc jetzt fällt die zweite
stufe weg wenn ein corona verdacht in
einer klasse besteht muss die schule
schnelltests für alle schüler
organisieren warum das zum problem
werden kann thomas münten
martina reiske in einer der leeren
klassen in ihrer bielefelder grundschule
vier klassen sind heute im distanz
unterricht trotz täglicher pc abhol
tests ab sofort sollen nun die schulen
auch noch die nach test und mit
schnelltests zu übernehmen die
schulleitung ist empört jetzt ist es so
dass die kinder auch wenn der klassen
positiv ist die kinder in die schule
kommen und von uns mit selbsttests
getestet werden müssen
es ist tragisch es ist erschreckend es
ist es breitet sich fassungslosigkeit
aus mehr kann ich da gerade nicht zu
sagen die neue regelung überlaste viele
grundschulen vermutet direktorin
schlimmer noch obwohl die regeln ab
heute umgesetzt werden sollen kamen sie
erst gestern am späten abend per mail
aus düsseldorf die opposition im landtag
spricht von organisiertem chaos
lehrerinnen und lehrer müssen kinder
testen wo sie wissen da ist mindestens
einer dabei der positiv ist das ein
zustand der geht nicht und wenn man dann
über nacht erst erfährt was am nächsten
morgen den schulen los ist dann ist das
keine gute kommunikation die
schulministerin aber sieht in den neuen
aufgaben kein problem die schulen sind
auskömmlich mit antigenen selbst aus
test ausgestattet sodass diese testungen
dann auch den an den schulen bei den
kindern entsprechend vollzogen werden
können morgen früh laufen die ersten
schnelltest wellen ein harter praxistest
für alle beteiligten
besonders viele corona fälle gibt es
derzeit in frankreich erstmals wurden
dort an einem tag mehr als 500.000
neuinfektionen gemeldet bei rund 67
millionen einwohnern auch der inzidenz
wert ist mit gut 3700 ein europäischer
negativrekord 95 prozent aller fälle
gehen auf omikron zurück die zahl der
patienten in krankenhäusern steigt die
intensivstationen sind davon aber
weniger betroffen als in früheren corona
wellen
zur ukraine krise wie lässt sich die
entschärfen dazu hatte moskau klare
forderungen an den westen gestellt so
müsse etwa eine aufnahme der ukraine
durch die nato vom tisch überhaupt solle
die nato ihre erweiterung in richtung
richtung osten stoppen jetzt am abend
eine antwort des westens
us-außenminister blinken verwies in
washington ein weiteres mal auf das
selbstbestimmungsrecht von staaten wie
der ukraine man sei aber weiter offen
für einen dialog
auch nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg will sich in diesen minuten
zu russlands forderungen äußern fragen
wir nach bei den kollegen in moskau und
washington zunächst zu elmar theveßen
mitten in die aufgeheizte stimmung kommt
jetzt also die offizielle antwort das
hat us aus münster blinken gesagt
ja die antwort ist schriftlich gegeben
worden und zwar in zweifacher
ausfertigung eine version von der nato
eine von den usa aber die sind
synchronisiert wie außenminister blinken
sagte da passt kein licht schweiz
wirklich zwischen diese beiden antworten
er hat gesagt dass die inhalte nicht
veröffentlicht werden weil man moskau
zeit geben will in ruhe darüber
nachzudenken aber er hat signalisiert
dass diese papiere das erfassen was
längst schon auf dem tisch liegt nämlich
eine klare absage daran dass man ukraine
und anderen möglicherweise eine
nato-mitgliedschaft verweigern sollte
und auch eine klare absage an einen
möglichen abzug aus nato truppen aus dem
baltikum und anderen osteuropäischen
staaten
außenminister bringen hat auch noch mal
sehr klar gemacht dass eine sehr harte
antwort kommen würde auf eine mögliche
invasion und das washington ein
absolutes vertrauen in die solidarität
deutschlands habe was die reaktion dann
auf solch eine invasion angeht jetzt
liege der ball in moskau putin alleine
könne darüber entscheiden und wie immer
er entscheidet so sagt außenminister
blinken die nato und die usa sind
vorbereitet der ball liegt in moskau
axel sturm gibt's da schon erste
reaktionen
nein es gibt zur stunde natürlich noch
keine reaktion vor etwa einer stunde ist
dieses treffen zu ende gegangen hier im
außenminister region von moskau der
amerikanische botschafter john sullivan
hat die schreiben überreicht an den
stellvertretenden russischen
außenminister groß co was drinsteht der
kollege sagte schon wissen wir zur
stunde natürlich noch nicht und wir
erwarten auch im laufe des morgigen
tages noch keine reaktion darauf wie
weit der verhandlungsmasse besteht über
diese russischen maximalforderungen will
ich sie mal nennen also keine ost
erweiterung der nato die ukraine
kategorisch ausschließen rückbau von
waffen aus osteuropa das werden wir dann
sehen das werden wir in den nächsten
tagen sehen aber hier gab es heute noch
eine andere interessante debatte in der
duma nämlich wo auch der russische
außenminister aufgetreten ist da hat
sörgel aber schon mal markige worte
vorab also vor der übergabe dieses
schreibens verwandte er sagte naja also
wenn die antwort aus den vereinigten
staaten nicht ausreichen dann werde man
hier antwort maßnahmen erarbeiten und
die präsident putin vorlegen also nach
außen hin gibt man sich hier immer
dialogbereit aber dann im zweiten oder
im dritten satz kommen dann immer
markige worte von deeskalation ist hier
wenig zu vernehmen wenig zu spüren
dankeschön nach moskau und washington
zurück nach deutschland und der frage
wie entwickelt sich die wirtschaft in
diesem jahr dazu hat jetzt
wirtschaftsminister habeck seinen
bericht vorgelegt für 2022 rechnet die
regierung mit einem wachstum von 3,6
prozent also fast einen prozentpunkt
mehr als im letzten jahr gleichzeitig
dürfte die arbeitslosenquote sinken auf
5,1 prozent
dunkle wolken gibt es aber auch die
preise steigen weiter 3,3 prozent
inflation im jahresschnitt werden
erwartet klaus projekt es ist eine
premiere in mehrfacher hinsicht der neue
wirtschaftsminister und ein
jahreswirtschaftsbericht der nicht nur
zahlen auf rein sondern gleich
zukunftsfragen lösen soll am ende wächst
die wirtschaft auch von mir pyramiden
bauen wie es früher hieß brauchen wir
aber nicht das hat sich erledigt und
dann sind wir beim kern politik der
wirtschaftspolitik dieser dieser
legislatur wie strukturieren und
fokussiert die programme so dass die
geschäftsfelder der zukunft erzielt
werden zu den altbekannten indikatoren
sollen neue hinzukommen etwa die
entwicklung des co2 ausstoßes um darauf
politisch besser einfluss nehmen zu
können die zeit dränge hatte habe zuvor
in seiner ersten regierungsbefragung im
bundestag erklärt noch eine premiere es
ist insofern erreicht dass die
wirtschaft der wird der hunger der
wirtschaft nach erneuerbaren energien zu
einem standortfaktor werden wird der
bayerische ministerpräsident scheint mir
denkt darüber nach ob dieser
zusammenhang auch für ihn gilt nur eine
minute erlaubt das parlament profi oder
antwort gleich mehrfach bleibt herr beck
deutlich drunter beispiel
bürokratieabbau wir wollen alle so
wichtigen gesetze in diesem jahr
verabschieden beispiel
überbrückungshilfen für unternehmen
wegen der pandemie sie sollen vorerst
weiterlaufen für den februar ist die
gleiche regelung gedacht wie wir im märz
da stehen werden wir dann sehen noch
dominiert corona alles da gibt es keine
premiere
die frühere generalsekretärin der spd
jasmin fach chemie soll vorsitzende des
deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes werden sie
wäre die erste frau an der spitze des
dgb die 54 jährige war bis 2013 in der
gewerkschaft bergbau energie und chemie
aktiv für chemie ist
bundestagsabgeordnete und im spd
parteivorstand
der bisherige dgb chef rainer hoffmann
tritt aus altersgründen bei der wahl im
mai nicht mehr an
erstes insolvenzverfahren jetzt folgt
ein weiterer rückschlag für die
belegschaft der mv werft in wismar der
eigentümer wollte die werft wohl ohnehin
schließen es gibt keine folgeaufträge
und damit kaum eine perspektive die
arbeiten am fast fertigen
kreuzfahrtschiff ruhen solange es keinen
käufer gibt die rund 2000 mitarbeiter
könnten ab märz in
transfergesellschaften kommen
zur größten seeschleuse der welt sie
soll kreuzfahrt schiffe und frachter von
der nordsee in den hafen von amsterdam
bringen
ist 500 meter lang und 18 meter tief
könig willem alexander hat sie feierlich
eröffnet allerdings gibt es auch kritik
an bauverzögerungen und explodierenden
kosten
zudem bringt jede schleusen öffnung
neues salz mit eine belastung für
trinkwasser natur und landwirtschaft
und damit sind wir schon beim sport der
handball-europameisterschaft
norbert da war es gestern ein
fulminantes spiel etwas ist spielen das
war nun er schafft als ein versöhnlicher
abschluss
auch ohne chance auf den halbfinaleinzug
erkämpfte sich das dhb team mit großer
leidenschaft einen knappen 30 29 sieg in
russland mit einem last-minute-tor aus
der trickkiste
drama hätte für die große bühne nicht
besser geschrieben werden können beim
stand von 29 29 nimmt trainer gislason
eine halbe minute vor schluss eine
letzte auszeit
und tatsächlich watt wortführer viele
wie bei den pass auf rechtsaußen serbe
der mit dem so genannten kempa-trick
hinüber auf linksaußen zieger spiels der
den ball fängt und dem russischen tor
versenkt als dann auch der letzte ball
der russen geblockt werden kann gelingt
dem deutschen team bei dieser durch
corona fast zur farce geraten ehe er
doch noch ein versöhnlicher abschluss
und zu recht werden die verbliebenen
deutschen neben und hauptdarsteller vom
publikum mit lang anhaltendem beifall
bedacht
der ehemalige werder trainer markus
anfang darf wegen der nutzung eines
gefälschten passes in dieser saison
nicht mehr als fußball coach arbeiten
das dfb sportgericht verhängte neben der
sperre eine geldstrafe von 20.000 euro
große überraschung gestern abend im
österreichischen schladming
skirennfahrer linus strasser gewinnt
dank eines famosen zweiten durchgangs
den legendären nachtslalom und beschert
den deutschen skiverband den größten
erfolg in diesem winter
endlich wieder ein sieg des münchners
skifahren es einfach sind brutaler sport
also dass es dieses zwischen leid und ja
so was so ein event nicht nur so viel
dazwischen und darum genieße ich das
gerade extrem straße hatte im ersten
lauf mit platz fünf die grundlage gelegt
fuhr im finale furioso auf der 50
prozent steilen planai piste ohne
wackler tisch klug und mit hauchdünnem
vorsprung auf den norweger max keiner
war mehr schneller der führende schwede
jacobsen fädelte ein und der 29 jährige
münchner
[Musik]
feierte seinen dritten weltcup sieg beim
letzten rennen vor olympia
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja damit ist linus straße natürlich auch
ein medaillenanwärter in beginnen und
das ist es
wo fährt noch die gewinnzahlen lauten 38
15 19 23 41 und die superzahl 6 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5
stürmische aussichten gibt es beim
wetter mehr dazu hat gleich ostern terli
um viertel vor zehn begrüßt sieht
marietta slomka im heute journal
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen und friedlichen
abend sagen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
beamte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ein sturmtief erreicht uns von
norden her und bringt teilweise
stürmischen wind im flachland und
sturmböen an den küsten und in den
bergen regen und schnee ist auch dabei
vor allem in den höheren lagen schauen
wir auf die nacht da gibt es viele
wolken im norden es gehört schon zum
sturmtief und regen ist dabei der wind
ist kräftig aus südwestlichen richtungen
teils stürmisch und auch sturmböen
können dabei seien im süden merkt man
wenig davon es klart teilweise auf oder
es bildet sich nebel und dort ist es am
kältesten temperaturen sinken bis auf
minus neun grad die frostgrenze verläuft
etwa über der mitte deutschlands sechs
grad plus gibt es richtung schleswig
holstein deutlich milder dort machen im
tagesverlauf wandern die wolken weiter
richtung mitte in den höheren lagen
oberhalb von 800 metern gibt es schnee
in den mittelgebirgen ansonsten im süden
sonnenschein ganz im norden der wind aus
nordwest bis west teils stürmisch mit
sturmböen durchaus möglich temperaturen
dazu höchste werte mit null grad im
vogtland und 9 grad im nordwesten es
geht es durchwachsen weiter mit schnee
am freitag an den alpen von 1 bis 8 grad
ja und samstag wird es weiterhin
stürmisch sein ein neues sturmtief
erreicht uns einen schönen abend damit